just Kidd he's a basketball phenom but
they'll be asking can this grown man
play at the next level we all trying to
understand each other using the game of
basketball as a backdrop
[Applause]
osition always mad at me
the kids got a lot bigger
um they're a lot bigger a lot faster a
lot stronger a lot of new stories a lot
of new Journeys same old J's
control things we see them in their
senior year where they're really feeling
this urgency to just figure out their
life you taught me to respect women I've
taught you to use common sense you're
gonna see Jay's coming into his own as a
man plus I got a car
[Music]
I am the athletic director at Cedar Cove
Academy Emery comes in and just
challenges Ike's perspective challenges
all of our characters is democracy a
destination or a journey
Jace is acting as a grown man so Jenna
is trying to find her peace in the storm
oh you'll be making any babies
[Music]
covering the politics of what's
Happening you think when a state
attracts donations what do you think
winning a High School National
Championship would attract and then also
between fathers and mothers and
daughters and sons since you've been out
of jail I'm happy I can't lose you again
I'm Matthew Mr she's still sleeping in
our bed it's not my fault we made a cute
ass baby I think something close put me
in position when I paid a price Peter
Pan dreams come from fighting through
the sacrifice this season is your last
hurray so let's go out with a bank
[Music]
basketball's authentic you see somebody
dunking they're dunking they're not
jumping off of a trampoline
I want you to remember this winners are
made on the court
Champions are made off the court the
issues that they deal with are just real
adult issues you got D1 college all this
going for you we can't be getting
caught up in those dumb this season
it's really important to know that even
when things get hard to not give up I'm
told you might have knowledge about who
attacked Joe Warren I never thought I'd
be going through this with huge haste
not like this
you got new characters we got new
players as well for me it was probably
one of the most special jobs I've had my
career
you guys have a hell of a season coming
at you get ready